la nouvelle agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines vient de voir le
jour édition spéciale du 7-8 politique
sur tv fil 78 en partenariat avec radio
sensations
nous verrons les changements à attendre
pour les habitants mais aussi les enjeux
politiques la droite largement
majoritaires quelle place pour
l'opposition
en plateau michel laugier président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines joséphine
coleman ce berger maire de plaisir et
première vice présidente ainsi que jean
michel fourgous maire d'elancourt lui
aussi une vice président est en charge
du projet économique d'un secteur qui
regroupe cent vingt-huit mille emplois
et plus de 16 mille entreprises
nous parlerons également de la place
réservée aux plus petites communes pour
intel encore exister également en
plateau alain gibert communiste de la
verrière